what's up reject nation greg and john
here today we are going to watch episode
2 of star wars visions we just watched
episode one that was awesome this one is
called a tattooing rhapsody oh i wonder
where we're going this time around guys
if you end up enjoying our reaction
please go ahead and hit that like button
and helps us out on the algorithm please
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our reactions
to the next star wars visions episode is
up as always full-length watch along as
we sync up with the time coder over at
our patreon page we cover a bunch of
shows over there with the same tier you
get the option for both reaction
highlights and watch alongs included
just finished avatar the last airbender
hell yeah also pratham jindal thanks for
writing this down for us buddy you rock
i would let you take a lightsaber to my
heart
in a
provocative manner
[Music]
[Music]
order 66
that would make a lot of sense
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
hey
uh hey guys we're sort of playing a gig
here
i have business with the slug come along
jabba's been looking for you
he brought it back yeah okay it's
definitely his voice
let's rock him
oh no that's a bad idea
he looks so adorable i know
chibi boba i want anime bobble head boba
oh
this is the third time now such
passionate fans we have yep that's just
the price of fame
slave wood
i just really want an autograph
i got a bad feeling about this hey
he said the line
[Music]
sexy
it's pointless to resist but i can't
wait i don't even know what i did you
know i don't care about hot legacy i
won't join jabba being part of that
syndicate is boring
jabba is not to be crossed what no wait
stop
you really want to do this
[Music]
oh
there's nothing we could have done
perhaps we were just lucky and our luck
ran out ultimately we're just a band
i know that
but i can't just abandon him after all
we've been through
[Music]
i finally got the band members i was
looking for our legend starts here
the first time we played together we had
a lot of fun that day
you were right kirti in the end we're
just a band just a band but music is
like the force
huh
huh
what what hey guy guys what are you
doing here we made a deal with jabba
to let us perform before he executes you
you don't need to get caught up in this
you should go
you guys are just
you're not one to run away from your
fans are you this'll be our biggest
venue since we formed the band geez
let's make this our best show ever plus
then when you're executed we'll be
legends and sell even more records
[Music]
calm down it's just a mic
two
one two three four
[Music]
tina
like an actual music
tap that tail
wow
[Applause]
we'll give you a chance we're gonna be
the number one band in the galaxy
how do you feel about becoming our first
sponsor
one more song
he's gonna make you plain as lair for
eternity
oh yeah they did it
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
they did it they're going to be the
greatest band in the galaxy
but when he was like
running
that that scene they kept cutting to was
that
a flashback or
a
vision of what he was hoping he could do
like imagine himself as
you mean the flashback when he first
meets uh his buddy on base
and he's like running away he's like
yeah
come with me
well the performance seems so different
yeah yeah and that moment seems kind of
sinister yeah it seems like very often
yeah we're a little like ominous so it
was a little bit confusing i didn't
like they looked the same but i didn't
think they were the same character yeah
but they were
that's how i took it okay they got to be
the same character we're just being
prejudiced against huts for looking
sinister their performance was so
different
like the performance that they're
hanging out is like i'm a dude in the
bed
it's like michael the other one was like
oh yeah
yeah i was a little confused for a
second really come with me on this
mission
it's all about partying and music gotcha
okay
all right cool let's talk about it oh
well that was a cute episode yeah that
was that was very definitely a shift
from the first episode sweet and
charming sans the like bounty pursuit
scenes it definitely feels more like
animatrix now more than ever to me yeah
because it's like you got two very
different animation styles
um with two very different um
feeling episodes overall two different
stakes varieties two different tones i
mean contextually i love the idea of
focusing on the band as your main
characters because there's bands in star
wars they even cut the cantina band at
one point here this was the the episode
i felt like with just so many easter
eggs all peppered in with your animation
just of who you can go like this
creature this creature that character
that character yada yada yada i find
myself sometimes getting bogged down
with timeline even though i don't think
this is like
considered canon that's what they said
yeah
but yeah it's like they're gonna pull
relevant references but it's not yeah
canonical so to speak yeah because uh i
was like boba's here okay so when in
timelines it's definitely before empire
yeah or before return of the jedi to say
the least yeah
um because then i saw i thought we saw
one of those droids from like the
prequels for a second and and then
that's why i was like oh is this during
the prequel time or six i was kind of
confused on when and then i found myself
getting a little distracted by that but
it was cool it was cute this is like a
cute one to me because
you know i like the i i i wish we saw a
conclusion of how this all went yeah
this felt like it was a snippet of a
larger show almost to me yes that was
like doing that anime thing where
occasionally they'll throw in a relevant
flashback that you've already seen
expanded in an earlier episode except we
don't have the earlier episode to go off
of yeah because i don't know if it's
supposed to be like meant for open to
interpretation for how it all goes down
or they're just playing their their one
last they wanted to be a band and be the
biggest band in the galaxy and this is
their chance to really perform you're
playing for one of the biggest gangsters
in all the galaxy
and then you're going out on a bang with
such a massive crowd who wants him to do
one more song and even choppa's
bobbing along with his little tail and
even boba's bobbing along you got all
this bobbing along happening
and
yeah so i'm like but does a friend die
yeah they still get executed they still
get executed
what about this young jedi that jay
seems to be is that just you know is
that is his microphone really just the
last vestiges of his old lightsaber uh i
mean to me if i'm taking it as a
flashback is that he was still in
padawan stage and that he was escaping
during order 66
and then he had to leave that life
behind yeah yeah there's a lot of
stories and star wars of characters who
are people who escaped during order 66
who were on their way to becoming
full-fledged jedis or just straight-up
jedis so
uh i i think it could be
to me that's how i took it yeah because
he's he has his hair done like about a
one day you know
and he's got a lightsaber that it seems
like he's turned into a microphone yeah
yeah yeah because at first i was like oh
is he gonna do some kind of switcheroos
they're gonna be a trick but no yeah i
mean it's a unique it's a unique idea
that contextually i like a lot of it
i mean i'm assuming he dies because it
seems like that what he wanted to do was
he couldn't save him so they didn't have
an escape plan out of here so we're just
gonna go out on a high yeah you know and
it's like it plays into that thing of
how japo likes performers uh you know
like his return of the jedi you see he
loves to be bestowed with entertainment
yeah he's jesters you know he's gonna
sign this band yeah he's not gonna sign
that he's gonna think he's gonna play
they're gonna kill him
i i kept thinking that or it's like the
only bargain you could possibly i think
hope to walk out of is if you are like
his music slaves and you just live there
and you only perform there yeah but i
don't think that's the case yeah i don't
think they would succumb to that they
agreed to let them have one more song
and that was it
so
yeah i guess it's kind of bleak i guess
i'm kind of trying to pick up on like
thematically
what it's about unity of the music
yeah it's funny because i liked seeing
the side of the universe i mean you know
there's obviously music throughout the
galaxy although in star wars media it's
not usually what we're focused on
because usually there are much more
intense stakes at hand but i liked it's
weird i liked the prospect of
stepping out into that side of the
universe just the more uh experiential
side of the universe and it felt
almost
a little at odds to me i guess because
like the linear progression of the story
is like we're in this pickle jabba you
know is basically collecting this debt
on his nephew or son or whatever the
relation is
and uh you know we gotta find some way
to alleviate this but it almost it felt
a bit more simple than that when we got
to the end of just like
they you know are all in for their
friend they play this great show
everybody loves the show they feel a
sense of triumph and then we're left to
wonder if they
live to play another day um and so yeah
at the outset it's like you have boba
and you've got jabba and you've got like
these recognizable things that i feel
like set you up to think that this is
gonna have some kind of greater context
which doesn't seem to really be there
yeah and the way they played with time
was just a little confusing for me as a
viewer
yeah it's like it felt like there was a
whole lot crammed in here it's weird the
first episode felt like it really
breathed in it in a good way in the in
the way where you're forgetting about
the a perfect short story it felt longer
than it actually is whereas this felt
like it was kind of crammed into the
time
yeah i'd say so i guess
i'm not sure i mean it might not be the
case
might just be our
dumb asses not fully understanding
the point of the episode maybe that's
hard to draw it's hard to draw a real
conclusion on my thoughts here maybe
they're counting on us trying to be like
gotta catch every little thing and
they're like no no we're just telling a
very straightforward story
man am i crazy i thought that he came
the the the hut on the band i thought he
came across totally different
when he i mean in that first scene when
he greets him and then that flashback
that keeps recurring like it does
it is it feels like an adult
yeah yeah yeah so i was like is that the
father of him or something or is this a
flash forward because i because i
thought for a second like is this a
flash forward where he this is him
trying to bail him out yeah you know
yeah
so i thought we were like maybe building
to that yeah that's where i thought we
were going and i was like oh it's
actually a flashback
yeah we're in a different spot in time
yeah
but no that's i guess what i got by the
end is just that's the first time they
met while he was while jay was fleeing
whatever circumstance and then you know
the hutt guy was just like yeah i need a
i need someone else for my band
greetings with some fuzzy guitar tones
yeah it was enjoyable it's one i need to
watch again
before i can fully form a solid concrete
opinion on it yeah i'm like am i just
thinking too hard about this or was this
a bit of a just kind of a fluffy episode
yeah perhaps but it's still fun and i
enjoyed the music and i enjoyed the
music too it was wonderfully animated
but uh
i still there's a bit of an emotional
punch that was still kind of missing for
me when it all never fully got there
emotionally i felt like i was still
digesting and taking in stuff before i
fully got somewhere with my heart yeah
and overall the impact to me feels a bit
and i don't
i hate to use the word but light it
feels like a lightweight kind of an
episode which isn't bad and i almost
wonder too if maybe they're also aiming
toward
not necessarily just us you know maybe
they are aiming to a more youthful
audience with this episode you know
because the first one is pretty dark and
you have to
appreciate certain styles of film and
animation and blah blah blah that a lot
of younger audiences probably aren't
familiar with so maybe they're spreading
around right right you know
well we'll see
what would you guys think of the episode
clarify for us
well in a minute when we don't fully get
something
clarify
we're gonna watch the third episode now
[Laughter]
but what did you love about it what did
you overall think what do you think the
point of this episode was be curious to
know
it was just like one of those one last
hurrahs just a good chance to hear
joseph gordon-levitt sing
that was jgl
he was the the speaking voice at least i
don't i don't know if he was the singing
voice but it's a decent match it sounded
like oh interesting
the jiggle sewed and i think he had
bobby boy in a hand in there and a
couple other people
all right well you know all right guys
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that bell hit that like button and
last but not least
niraj krishnan literally looked at our
patreon page and said who at our patreon
would most be in a band and it's pretty
apparent to be you they're constantly
recommending music to us that really
feels like they're from a galaxy far far
away most of the time john and i have
never heard of
these this musician this style of music
or anything of that nature feels very
foreign to us
we usually stick in our lane america
the world
and we view the world as pretty much
just america so i appreciate you opening
our eyes to
galaxy of songs
john
please say something and our ears niraj
thank you also for opening our ears to a
galaxy of songs i would love to travel
the universe in your band you know
imagine you reaching your hand out to me
being like come on john i need an
average to moderately okay guitar player
and i'll be like really mirage you think
i have it in me thanks for saving me
from certain death i could see you crowd
surfing even during the pandemic
especially especially using with the
kind of guy who just wouldn't give a
[ __ ] that's right i hope your family is
watching and knows the kind of attitude
you have
carelessness
thank you so much for being part of our
patreon paige and raj
[Music]